all right welcome back so it has been 25
years since the murder of tupac shakur
and on september 1st the mod museum will
host a riveting discussion concerning
the murder of tupac all of the
controversies that followed and his
legacy that continues on and here to
tell us more about the event is director
of public programs for the mob museum
shakayla alvarenga shakayla thank you so
much for being here thank you we were
talking a little bit before we started
this interview and this is a really
special event tell us a little bit about
what we can expect
absolutely so as you mentioned the mob
museum will be holding a panel
discussion this wednesday september 1st
to mark the 25th anniversary of the
tupac shakur murder and it
it's hard to believe you know that it's
been that long but
this shooting that happened just off the
las vegas strip was one of the biggest
crimes that happened in las vegas
history so we are bringing together
really a diverse range of perspectives
to recount that fateful night and to
discuss what led up to that shooting
here in las vegas yeah and it's hard to
believe that it's been 25 years and
again this is a very talked about
situation so who are some of the special
appearances that are going to be there
at this event on the first absolutely so
and just going off of what you said i
think that there's a lot of fascination
surrounding this story
because of the mystery that that
surrounds it since you know way back in
in the 90s and still to this day you
know no arrests have been made in the
tupac shakur murder so there is a lot of
you know conspiracy theories that have
sprouted from that but a lot of interest
still remains in tupac shakur's legacy
and so we are bringing together a great
group of panelists this wednesday edi i
mean he was an original member of the
outlaws tupac shakur's friend he was
traveling behind
mr shakur during the night of the
shooting and we also have stephanie
frederick who will be our moderator for
the evening and she has been an
executive producer a former journalist
and she also worked on the biopic all
eyes on me
and
we also have chuck d who is a rapper and
amazing yeah founder of public enemy and
he also played such a pivotal role in
you know the art of rapping so we're
excited to have him well it is very
exciting and a lot to unpack there and
if you can't make it out for the event
you guys will be recording it so people
can watch it back that event is
happening though on september 1st at the
mob museum 7 to 8 30. a lot going on
thank you so much